hello everybody welcome to this week
science live live chat on what have we
learned about dinosaurs in Jurassic Park
from the peg being the recent release of
the 3d version of the original Jurassic
Park movie and the upcoming Jurassic
Park 4 scheduled for release in the
summer of 2014 I'm Robert koontz deputy
news editor at science magazine and my
guests with us today are Stephen Drew
sadi at the University of Edinburgh
Scotland a paleontologist and Jack
Horner of the museum of the rockies in
Bozeman Montana dr. Bersani is a expert
on the origin extinction of dinosaurs
and their development into the dinosaurs
that nowadays we call birds and dr.
Horner is an expert in dinosaur growth
and behavior and he's been the
scientific advisor for all four Jurassic
Park movies I'm sure he'll have a lot to
say about that though everybody with us
now I before we start on those of you
who are listening in watching us you can
leave questions of your own in the box
below the section that says related
articles there's a little comments box
down there just send them in we have
plenty of comments already people are
just very curious about what they have
to say now presumably dr. Horner will
answer most questions about the movie
but they'll be played there are a lot of
sort of general dinosaur related
questions do there come in um I think
that the you know a good way to start
would be just kind of by with the
question that we picked as the type of
the live chat what have we learned about
dinosaurs what are the major discoveries
that we've made we didn't know when the
original
Jurassic Park movie was released 20
years ago um shall we start with dr.
Prasad II sure yeah hello everybody hi
from from Scotland we've learned a huge
amount about dinosaurs over the past 20
years and you know Jurassic Park played
a big role in that in motivating a new
generation of people to become
interested in dinosaurs and some of them
like me went on to study dinosaurs and
make a career out of paleontology and I
think what's really changed is there's a
lot of new fossil discoveries about a
new species of dinosaur is being found
every week or so from somewhere around
the world and also just a lot of new
technological advances so we regularly
study dinosaurs now with CT scanners to
look inside the brain cases to look at
details of the internal anatomy we use
bone histology that's something that dr.
Horner does quite a bit of a look at how
dinosaurs grew we use various chemical
techniques to look at what dinosaur
bones are made out of we study isotopes
to see what the body temperatures of
dinosaurs might be so dinosaur
paleontology is integrated with many
other sciences and because of this we're
learning literally every week new things
about dinosaurs dr. harder I agree I I
really you know I think we've probably
learned nearly as much about dinosaurs
since Jurassic Park came out as we knew
prior to it coming out I mean we you
know it's the knowledge that we are
getting we have so many people working
on dinosaurs now we're just it's it's
that's just now oh yeah our readers are
or our questioners are asking how that
knowledge is going to be translated into
the next Jurassic Park movie now you
know we don't there's not even a script
yet but let me just scroll through here
because I remember seeing a question
hold on a second will try to give
everybody a chance here
okay there are several questions that
who are asking about well a lot about
feathered dinosaurs and the recent
discoveries and whether the dinosaurs in
the Jurassic Park 4 are going to reflect
more current understandings of the
nature of dinosaurs or whether for the
sake of continuity they'll have to look
more like the dinosaurs of the previous
Jurassic Park movies of any clue about
that well first off I know there was
something said by them by the director
that they're made that the dinosaurs
wouldn't have feathers but I can assure
you that Steven Spielberg will make that
decision then I can also assure you that
the that the scientific advisor will
strongly recommend that dinosaurs have
feathers ok 50 here um we have a couple
of questions I know we don't we don't
want to give them away too much and
there's not a lot to give away at this
point presumably because the movie
hasn't even started shooting yet but a
questioner cook called indeed um asks
what can you tell us about Jurassic Park
4 and why do you think it's going to be
scary and other people also seem to ask
about this scare content um I thought
the first ones where we're scary enough
is this one going to take it to new
levels of terror well i don't know that
i can say that i can't really say too
much about what we're doing right now
but but I it's a I can assure you that
the dinosaur the star dinosaur will be
very scary yes ok we won't ask anymore
about that I want to be surprised okay
first of all heavy
have you actually seen the 3d release of
Jurassic Park one yet I have no
unfortunately I'm looking forward to
seeing it but have not seen it no I
haven't either i don't think it's out in
the UK yet i could be wrong about that
but um but i'm looking forward to seeing
myself whenever I whenever I can yeah
yeah I want to see it in imax that's the
only way to see 3d as far as I'm
concerned none of their opportunities
around here okay let's turn to some more
questions here and for those of you
who've just arrived remember you can
submit questions of your own down in the
box under the related articles section
now just just a down down there down
there not at the bottom of the page but
just a just a smidge below where we are
okay a questioner named will the blank
asks what is the current understanding
of DNA recovered from dinosaur fossils
is if actual Dino DNA rather than
contamination how common is DNA
preserved in fossils not just dinosaur
fossils and he's talking about Permian
age fossils older than dinosaurs and how
complete is the DNA and contractions be
identified as actual dinosaur and what
is contained in these fragments and what
do they code for that's quite a mouthful
um any word on dinosaur or pre dinosaur
DNA Jack I think you should take that
one as well that is you were it's a
simple answer there is no dinosaur DNA
that has ever been found the mary
schweitzer in her group has located and
identified proteins in particular
collagen but DNA has not been found and
I Stephen do you remember how old the
oldest is it's not very old yeah I don't
think it's very old at all
thousands of years not even close to a
million so no DNA yeah the recent
discussion of resurrecting extinct
species does not apply to dinosaurs um
we're talking more Pleistocene mammals
and yeah if you're talking about some
kind of cloning using DNA that is true
and yet we have a couple of
questionnaires here hold on a second
i'll scroll through these who asked
about a project to replicate dinosaurs
from birds starting with fern embryos
hello can you comment on that that is a
project that we have put on going here
at Montana State University it is also a
project that we're doing in conjunction
with Hans Larsen at McGill University
and basically what we're trying to do is
reactivate what we call Anna mystic
genes in other words reactivate some of
basically turn a bird like a chicken
which is easy to get a hold of going to
turn on some of its ancestral
characteristics like a tail give it a
longer tail and give it three fingered
hands instead of the wing structure and
reactivate T so it's a it's not a real
project to make a real dinosaur it's a
project to kind of back up you know in
quotes back up evolution and give us an
idea of what you know a dinosaur might
have looked like okay um how we could
ask Steve what he thinks of that project
hey I'm anxiously awaiting it you know
jack published a book a couple of years
ago that I think sold quite a lot of
copies and it was about this project so
you know a lot of us in the queue
are anxiously looking forward to seeing
what Jack and Hans can do because it's
really interesting you know a lot of
these characteristics that the ancestors
of birds had like towels and teeth
three-fingered hands you know these
things are still hidden away in the
genome in some form there are still some
genes in living birds the code for those
things so there have been you know
chickens or other birds and labs that
have been made to grow teeth for
instance so it's very possible and I
know that within the next few years I'm
sure jack and his guys will present
something pretty neat so what what will
look like what if you succeed what
exactly will you have in your lap well
it'll be a chicken with a long tail and
and three fingered hand instead of
instead of the stumpy little thing you
know when you eat when you eat chicken
you pull apart its its wing to eat it
and the fingers are all fused together
it they will all be separate you know it
isn't going to look the first generation
of this creature will not look much
different than a chicken other than the
fact that it will have an actual tail
and you don't want to secure you know
what you won't want to stick your finger
in its mouth little countdown is
division so is fit this is what I'm
expecting but you know as a skeleton as
a skeleton it will it will you know
because dinosaur morphology and bird
morphology really are you know very
close to one another except for the tail
in the hands and a bird with with these
characteristics will look very much like
the little Solaris Orion dinosaurs when
you'll keep those small specifically
well you know the sixth graders would
like us to make them dick but but I I
keep trying to I remind them that you
know the bigger they are the more chance
I'll just eat their makers
must be you that always happens you know
well it certainly happened in Mary
Shelley's booked in them uh-huh okay
we've got some more coming in some of
them are a little bit technical um right
here's one who lists himself calls
himself Steve's number one fan hmm yeah
that's a good recommendation hey Weston
at what point do you think dinosaurs
became endothermic and then he helpfully
ads in or she hopefully ads in
parentheses warm-blooded also what is
okay before welding after the second one
um so at what point did dinosaur has
become warm-blooded Steve's number one
and only fan I think that's an
interesting question we don't know for a
fact which if any dinosaurs were truly
endothermic in the sense that living
mammals and birds are but we do know
that the most if not all dinosaurs grew
very fast had very active metabolisms
and overall were much more like birds
and they were like reptiles and that's
really true of all dinosaurs and we can
tell that by looking at thin sections of
their bones the histology work the jack
and a lot of his colleagues have done
have shown that that dinosaurs grew very
fast they grew to adult size even
species like t-rex within 20 years big
dinosaurs the long neck dinosaur because
these things didn't live to be hundreds
of years old but reached adult size in a
few decades so it seems like all
dinosaurs had that kind of metabolism at
which point true bird-like endothermic
internal control of body temperatures
where that evolved is a bit debatable
the earliest birds like Archaeopteryx
and Confuciusornis those type of things
they're not even fully bird-like in
their growth rates so it seems like
somewhere in that theropod bird
transition is probably where the true
avian style emerged but there's a lot of
ongoing work about that okay
we've had another question I remember it
i'm scrolling down can't can't find the
actual questioner but i remember last
week someone was very curious about the
downing fossils and asked why do all the
really great dinosaur fossils seem to
come from china nowadays go ahead Steve
I know yeah it's true mental a lot of
these feathered dinosaurs pretty much
all of them are from China except for a
few handfuls of them and China is a
place right now where a lot of exciting
work is being done it's a big country
there's a lot of fossils to be found
there there's an emerging generation of
Chinese colleagues of ours of younger
researchers and students that are doing
a lot of great work and with leaning in
particular really we're just very lucky
that those rocks were deposited in the
right type of environment that soft
tissues like feathers but also things
like muscles and skin and sometimes
internal organs could be preserved
because it was predicted decades ago
that some dinosaurs probably had
feathers but it took until the mid-90s
the discovery of this perfect setting
for that to be confirmed yeah I you know
I would just add to that you know what
anything that we find you know it's it's
just luck and it's luck concerning what
age rocks are exposed to the surface of
the ground and China just happens to be
a place where there's a lot of the right
age rock for dinosaurs exposed at the
surface of the ground and the right
geological settings for you know he's
longer what we call lighter Staten
highly preserved specimens okay
hopefully we'll find some more another
parts of the world so here's a question
from me for both of you where would you
most like to dig that is not currently
being explored
hmm hmm if you've had a choice boy some
really good question i mean a lot of the
world now is being explored i mean you
know dinosaurs have been found on every
continent there's you know people from
from all over the world universities
museums all over the world that are
looking for dinosaurs so there the
number of untouched areas uh that's
fairly limited now but what I'm really
mostly interested in is trying to better
understand the origin of dinosaurs that
process where dinosaurs went from you
know their first ancestor and assume
dominance became these large body very
successful very globally widespread
animals that we treasure so that
happened during the Triassic period
about 250 to 200 million years ago so
I'm always interested in trying to find
new field sites that preserve rocks of
that age that were deposited in the
right environment and especially are
from places in the world that haven't
been as well explore so there's been a
lot of Triassic work in Western North
America quite a bit in South America but
much less in places like Europe in
Africa and I am and I actually you know
I'm not looking for new places to look
I'm actually my kind of research that I
do I am NOT looking for new taxa I'm
actually looking for for lots and lots
and lots of the same species of
dinosaurs so I'm looking for places
where I can just get tremendous numbers
of individuals of 11 species so so I'm
you know Mike places that I'm likely to
look are you know only a few miles from
places I've already looked I'm hoping to
hit the jackpot okay makes sense okay
Joe Sullivan last week posted a question
how come we are not finding aquatic
dinosaurs after 154 million years of
evolution you would think that one
branch ventured into the water
I know of the pressure of marine
reptiles in the presence of the muscular
presence of marine reptiles of the
oceans but still they could have carved
a niche think about it they ventured
into the air and now brewing dinosaurs I
would suggest you take a look at
jurassic park three where we have
Spinosaurus in the water okay yeah I
think that's a good question i mean
there were some dinosaurs like
Spinosaurus that probably did live kind
of at the water's edge and probably
hunted fish and had something of a
semi-aquatic existence but there isn't
anything like a dinosaur equivalent of a
whale or a shark or anything like that
um it's a good question you know some
birds have become somewhat aquatic
things like penguins or there were many
diving birds during the the last part of
the age of dinosaurs some crocodiles
during the time of dinosaurs became
essentially fully aquatic they had very
well like bodies they could swim very
fast they were hunters of fish in the
open oceans but as far as we know no
dinosaurs could do that I've heard you
know people talk about a couple of
things maybe because dinosaurs laid eggs
it was hard for them to give birth in
the oceans a lot of these reptile groups
that assumed an aquatic existence things
like ichthyosaurs and please a source
gave birth to live young maybe dinosaurs
just for some reason weren't able to
evolve that maybe the lungs of dinosaurs
presented some kind of problem it seems
like a lot of dinosaurs at very
bird-like lungs and although we do see
some birds that are like penguins that
are kind of aquatic we don't see these
fully aquatic ones so maybe there's
something about that way of breathing
but that's pretty far outside of my area
of expertise so i think i'm jose a
question is a really good one and I you
know I'd love to hear an answer to it
yeah broadening that question a little
bit what other facets of dinosaur
diversity might we expect to find that
we haven't found yet I mean there there
are whole types of
for example that don't seem to have
dinosaur analogs I haven't discovered
dinosaur elephants or kangaroos yet what
are some of the strangest dinosaurs taxa
that we have found so far especially in
the last 20 years and what else you know
might one expect to find in the future
we're doing science fiction here you
know that's right well fortunately nice
thing is that when we're creating
dinosaurs for Jurassic Park we actually
can do we can actually kind of do that
and I won't say anything more about
Jurassic Park 4 but but there's always
that possibility yeah I think um you
know dinosaurs did quite a bit when when
we think about just the the huge range
of sizes they evolved into some of the
weird body plans like you know the
long-necked sauropod so it's not really
anything alive today like that so
dinosaurs were quite diverse in size and
in shape and in their ecology and there
of course flying dinosaurs and burrowing
dinosaurs I think what's coming to light
now as more people are looking for
fossils is that there was a huge
diversity of very small dinosaurs and
it's sometimes hard for the smallest
dinosaurs to become fossils you know
it's just smaller animals their
skeletons are more fragile so it's
harder for them to enter the fossil
record but newer discoveries are showing
that when we do see small dinosaurs
preserve the line expand on these
loggers dot and type settings like Jack
mentioned in landing in China there's a
huge diversity so I think the next weird
body plan of a dinosaur will probably be
one of the something that comes from one
of these sites that preserve small
dancers in fact kelly banco just one
minute ago said the question are there
any known examples of very small
dinosaurs less than say a foot or so
yeah yeah there are obviously you know
birds um but but not you know it's
putting birds aside for a second there
have been a handful of things in recent
years that have been found a lot of
things from China a lot of these
feathered dinosaurs are quite small they
would have been you know a foot or two
long way maybe just a few kilograms and
there's some things from North America
as well some small Velociraptor type
dinosaurs some small plant eaters things
that would have been about the size of a
miniature poodle or something like that
so yeah there are small dinosaurs they
might not get as much press assume the
bigger dinosaurs but they were certainly
there in important parts of the
ecosystems and some of the baby
dinosaurs we have a really tiny yeah
okay you mentioned the Spinosaurus
here's a rat their technical question
well I think has to go to Jack although
Steve can weigh in if he wants to Chris
Johnson last week asked technically
speaking the t-rex should have crippled
the Spinosaurus after the bite to the
neck i assume he's talking about
something that happened in that third
wheel hub that completes doing this we
have the t-rex's bite pressure it should
have knocked it to the ground with the
head but the spy nose leg in the
Jurassic Park pre-fight see I know it's
the movies and there's no true way of
knowing which one would win in a fight
but what carnivorous dinosaur is the
true king it could possibly not even be
either of those two well obviously the
true king of dinosaurs is Tyrannosaurus
Rex which obviously is you know king is
in its name but you know in the movie
jurassic park three we needed we needed
a bad guy and we needed something to
take the dress it take the t-rex out of
the out of the picture for a little
while so so Spinosaurus being the
largest meat-eating dinosaur that we
know of well that just had to be at that
yet win but for dramatic purposes you
need to needed a big fat dinosaur but
you're not going to you're not going to
take sides about which one of them was
the actual biggest meanest exactly okay
a slightly related question edmund
walnut from Nova Scotia as
by dr. Horner of all is going well
friend of yours can you tell me what you
think t-rex was a scavenger and not a
predator well I thought that's a long
thing to go into I just suffice to say
that if you compare a Tyrannosaurus to
say a Velociraptor and just look at the
morphology of the two animals they're
very different from one another and so
it was a problem that I posed actually
originally in a class and the whole idea
was for students to attempt to start out
the problem without a preconceived idea
of what it was in other words look only
at the data look only at morphology and
see if they could just you know come to
some kind of conclusion as to what it
might have been and so t-rex being so
different than the velociraptors in
their shapes and and and many other
things including how big they are which
is certainly an animal it is not going
to be very agile and the fact that they
have these you know huge bone crushing
teeth you know it at least can move you
in sort of that direction a direction
you would not move with a velociraptor
any comments you yeah well this is a fun
little debate I remember seeing the
museum exhibit that Jack did about a
decade or so ago it must have been a
traveling exhibit about this issue and
it is a neat thing to get people
thinking about using fossil evidence
which is very limited to infer diet and
behavior and lifestyle um I would say
that I would be quite surprised if t-rex
was a pure scavenger there really isn't
anything alive today that that is a pure
scavenger at that size that lives in a
terrestrial ecosystem that isn't able to
fly around and cover a lot of ground but
I'm sure like any carnivore lions or
you know grizzly bears or whatever the
case may be t-rex would have hunted it
would have scavenged it would have taken
whatever food it could have gotten it
surely wouldn't turn down a free meal we
do know that it did hunt done at least
some occasions there are some instances
of Triceratops and at montes oras bones
that show bite marks that seem to match
those of t-rex and they show signs of
regrowth so there does seem to be you
know evidence that t-rex was hunting
that this animal survived the attack but
um so I think um you know t-rex was an
apex predator but probably also a
scavenger when the opportunity presented
itself but fossil evidence we can only
infer these things well I would argue
that as you could imagine okay questions
are writing but before I read the next
one let me just remind those of you who
have just arrived recently but this is
the science life live chat first one on
video and the topic of the day is what
have you learned about dinosaurs Sims
Jurassic Park hey let's see what we've
got coming in here okay Steve's number
one fan he just keeps firing off music
is it says that the big question
explored in Jurassic Park was whether if
we can should we bring back dinosaurs
what is your opinion about that now
actually jack has already talked about
is experiment in trying to come up with
dinosaur light creatures by activating
suppressed genes in chickens on other
verbs is there an ethical dimension to
this that if you'd like to weigh in on
oh boy being quizzed about ethics um
most of my family are lawyers so after
my brothers and one of the backwards I
hit him and see what he thinks but um I
don't know about ethics but what I would
say is that you know dinosaurs things
like t-rex and Triceratops those kind of
dinosaurs they went extinct purely
naturally humans had nothing to do
with that and they went extinct a long
time ago so if we did bring them back we
wouldn't be bringing back something like
a woolly mammoth that we had a hand in
their extinction and if we did bring
back a dinosaur's we'd be bringing them
into an environment that was very
different from the environment that they
actually evolved and lived in so I think
those are issues that we have to keep in
mind but as Jack was talking about you
know we just don't have dinosaur DNA now
that will probably never happen I
seriously doubt we'll ever get to this
point where the lawyers get involved we
start debating the ethics I agree okay
okay long as we're bouncing around and
giving fairly random questions Jamie
esser asks cites a line from dr. Ian
Malcolm in Jurassic Park which he
stumbles on a huge pile of dinosaur dung
he says yes what have we learned about
dinosaur coprolites since the movie's
premiere in 1993 I can tell you one
thing for sure yeah we've learned that
they're not dead you know there's I
would call it the dumb rule the file
can't be any higher than the place it
came from we sort of broke that rule in
Jurassic Park dinosaur we you know we
have found we have Tyrannosaurus dung
and it is not that big it is a more
manageable sizes yeah Jamie that's a
good question um you know people do
study dinosaur coprolites there are a
lot of people to study them but
occasionally they can't tell you some
pretty interesting things about how
dinosaurs actually lived what kind of
food they ate and the t-rex coprolite
that Jack mentioned yeah it's not huge
it's not like a ton pile of you know
dinosaur crap but it is you know about a
foot long or so and it's full of bone so
it tells us that t-rex did chomp through
the bones of its prey when it fed which
is an amazing thing that's very unusual
type
behavior that the jaw muscles and the
bike course you would need to do that is
pretty extreme there's coprolites of
duck-billed dinosaurs that have pieces
of decaying wood in them so it seems
like these animals may have supplemented
their diet with with rotting logs maybe
10 times when when when you know plants
were scarce during the dry season or
something like that so occasionally
dinosaur coprolites although it sounds
kind of weird we do actually learn some
neat things from
a lot of people are asking questions
about the about the next movie I think
that's not exactly on topic well it's a
secret anyway so we're not going I'm not
going we're not going there nerd I'd
like to know too but Jack and I were
talking me for this he's not spilling
okay curious asks where dinosaurs really
that dumb there are some really smart
birds with a small brain compared to
their body size brain to body ratio
whatever the tech to determine success
now of course in the movies as we know
the dinosaurs weren't all stupid that
velociraptors were very intelligent and
later on they even seem to develop
language but um what is the current
thinking about dinosaur intelligence I
actually have a student looking and
brain to body ratios and I think it I
think that once the information comes
out people are going to be very
surprised and that dinosaur brain body
ratios are higher than normally thought
of but I won't go there because that's
students research well Steve you're
interested in birds some of which we
know are very intelligent yeah we we
actually you know are learning quite a
bit about dinosaur intelligence through
student projects like like Jack's
student is doing and there's a lot of
people working on this now and that's
mostly because CT scanners have become
such a useful tool for paleontologists
because it used to be that if you wanted
to know anything about the brains of a
dinosaur you'd have to basically cut
open a skull and look at the brain
cavity and maybe make a latex mold of
the brain cavity and you know take that
out and measure its volume and compare
it to the brains of living animals or
whatever you'd like to do but obviously
that's not something we want to do one
of the first skulls of t-rex I was ever
was cut up that way but nowadays we can
sit these skulls and CT scanners and
digitally reconstruct what the brains
would have looked like and this has been
done for a lot of dinosaurs and it does
look like a lot of at least the
carnivorous dinosaurs had quite large
brains they were probably quite keen in
terms of their senses things like
tyrannosaurs and dromaeosaurs for
example had really large olfactory bulb
so they had really good senses of smell
so this is a really work in progress but
I think this idea that dinosaurs were
these big dumb you know animals plotting
around waiting to go extinct that's
completely outdated and I think Jurassic
Park started you know the transition
away from thinking like that especially
with how things like Velociraptor were
portrayed
Peter Krause asks did dinosaurs sound
like crocodiles platypus making gurgle
sounds or did some of them develop the
ability to sing like birds if some
dinosaurs have a syrinx yeah you know in
our dinosaur Hall here at the Museum of
the Rockies since we don't know what
dinosaur sounded like there is you know
there has been some research done
originally by a David why sample and and
some others in New Mexico looking at
blowing air through some of the duckbill
dinosaur nariyal cavities and we've done
that very same thing here to get an idea
of pitch and we certainly can determine
by doing something like that that that
dinosaurs dinosaur juveniles made very
high pitch sounds and I us or if if in
fact they made sounds blowing air
through their nasal capsules and that
large dinosaurs with very large crests
on their heads would make very deep
sounds infrasounds and so when I make
when i create dinosaur sounds for our
dinosaur Hall I just basically take bird
sound and slow it way down because then
I know for sure it's a dinosaur sound
view
yeah you know a lot of that speculative
but some of this work that the jack
mention has been done people using CT
scans to build digital models of these
duck-billed dinosaurs and then using
computer programs to simulate what
sounds no may have been produced another
avenue to understanding dinosaur sound
is looking at dinosaur brains and
dinosaur in arrears with CT scans and
some of that work has shown it won't
tell you you know exactly what sounded
dinosaur made but it's shown that
animals like t-rex have ears that were
capable of hearing very low frequency
sounds just comparing the shapes of the
ears to those of living animals so we're
learning more and more about even some
of these things that we used to think
we're completely in the realm of
speculation wait um Michael Cantor asks
what have we learned about colors and
marking of dinosaurs sends Jurassic Park
how is the oh well okay let's just talk
about you know there are there actual
physical appearance do you want to go
huh yeah that's another one of these
things that I used to be thought I was
completely speculative you know what
color was a t-rex and in most cases is
probably very hard to tell but over the
last few years I think one of the
neatest things that paleontologists have
discovered is that in some cases if you
have a really well preserved fossil you
might be able to tell what color what
dinosaur was and the way this works is
if you have feathers preserved and you
look at those feathers under very
high-powered microscopes sometimes if
the preservation is good enough you can
see these individual pigment cells
called melanocytes what one of the
things that gives feathers of birds and
also you know the colors of feathers of
birds their colors and also gives other
structures in nature color and different
milana somes of different shape
corresponding different colors so you
can get a rough estimate sometimes just
by looking at those milana somes if
they're there looking at their shape and
that's told some scientists that some of
these feathered dinosaurs like
Microraptor probably had
an iridescent coat kind of like a crow
or something like that another dinosaur
anchiornis and other one of these great
birds like feathered dinosaurs seem to
have had some red feathers along its
back those kind of things so it's not
easy to do this but there is a way in
some cases to predict what what colored
dinosaurs would have been using real
fossil evidence speaking of appearance I
understand that population studies of a
lot of dinosaurs that died in similar
times and comparative physiology of
dinosaurs of different stages their
evolution have caused some species of
dinosaurs to disappear some of the Torah
Soros and Triceratops and a few others
would you like to bring us up to date
about some of those dinosaurs that might
have been some of our childhood
favorites that might no longer have
existed as independent creatures god
that's a lot of what we're doing here at
the Museum in the Rockies it it really
it's it's it's a little simpler than
that actually it's a what we've
discovered is that that many dinosaurs
back virtually all of them that we have
a good growth series of from juveniles
to adults change pretty drastically and
the juveniles look very different than
the adults but what's even more
interesting is that light birds the
juvenile characteristics remain until
the animals are almost full-grown so so
that means that that an animal what a
dinosaur triceratops is a good example
can have a two metre long skull and
still not have its adult morphology
which you will get when the skull is
three meters long now it's controversial
but one of the things that we're looking
at is is looking at
at these growth stages is actually
taking bone samples out and looking at
their bone histology and and seeing that
animals like Triceratops that we thought
was as a full-grown animal is actually
still growing right along even with a
two metre long skull so we know it's
going to get a lot bigger and the only
animal that we have that's a lot better
is an animal called Torosaurus so I
don't know if anyone had a Torosaurus
for a childhood favorite but if they did
sorry but we're forget they were
recovered of that one I'd say that in
most cases the the animals that have
been sunk have actually been named
pretty recently in most cases so I don't
think we've actually sunk many of the of
the of the favorites except brontosaurus
well I was a different that was a whole
different situation behind them okay um
we've had a couple of questions come in
just in the past couple of minutes
people are asking about the extinction
of the dinosaurs Valerie asks regarding
the extinction of the dinosaurs what
does the current evidence indicate as
far as the asteroid impact or volcanic
eruptions being more responsible any
evidence for diseases or other factors
leading to their extinction and Stephen
wheaty asks the at says the asteroid or
comet theory of extinct it looks pretty
good and there's something about super
volcanoes any thoughts so extinction
time Steve you have to answer that
because I don't care I know jack always
does list you know that care more about
how dinosaurs lived then how they died
I'm quite interested in the extinction
because it does give us a picture into
how evolution happens and because it was
so integral in the rise of mammals after
dinosaurs went extinct mammals had their
chance to rise up and it seems like a
lot of these Keystone moments in eville
solution happen after he's often sudden
unpredictable extinctions the dinosaur
extinction the most famous mass
extinction really in Earth history about
66 million years ago it's been in the
news a lot recently because there have
been ill there's been a lot of new
research looking at this extinction we
know for a fact that there was an
asteroid that hit the planet or a comet
66 million years ago and we don't have
dinosaur fossils in the rock record
after that we know there was an asteroid
because we have crater in Mexico that
matches the age this is greater that
matches about a 10 kilometer wide
asteroid or so we have this worldwide
layer of clay that's enriched in iridium
this element that is very rare on earth
very common in asteroids and comets and
there's evidence for global wildfires
and tsunamis and also or something so we
know an asteroid impact happened but
there does remain this question of
whether or not that impact solely was
responsible for the death of the
dinosaurs or whether there may have been
other factors because there were big
volcanic eruptions going on during the
last few million years of the Cretaceous
in India huge volcanic eruptions there
were very drastic temperature changes
there were big sea level changes and it
seems like some of these things may have
been affecting dinosaur populations
there's some evidence from North America
which really is the only place in the
world where we have good fossils of
dinosaurs during the last ten million
years of the Cretaceous there's evidence
there that at least some dinosaur groups
the plant-eating dinosaur groups were
undergoing some kind of decline their
diversity was becoming less and less
over time so whether that factored into
their extinction or not it's hard to say
but it may have been that this weakening
of diversity due to volcanism due to
temperature changes due to sea level
changes may have made dinosaurs more
susceptible to the effects of that
asteroid that's just one idea but the
pitchers becoming clearer and clearer
and there's a lot of new work in this
area Kelly by panko three minutes ago
just sitting the question was dinosaur
herding behavior widespread
and I i'm curious about just what we
know about dinosaur social behavior and
organization well I i we certainly you
know hurting is a is a big word and
suggests a lot of things we certainly
have evidence of dinosaur aggregations
in other words we find these these we
find a lot of mass accumulations of what
we call multi mono specific groups so we
know that they at least died together
and we assume that if they died together
in a group they probably were living
together in a group that doesn't
necessarily mean that they were in
actual structured heard although this
whole business of the juveniles looking
different than the adults and the adults
looking different than the juveniles
certainly suggests that that if they
really group together they they
certainly were very social animals so so
I you know if we use the term heard very
generally I'd say yes we have very good
evidence that dinosaurs lived in heard
like structures of aggregations of many
different kinds many up virtually all
the duck-billed dinosaurs and the horn
dinosaurs and we're even finding what
you know what could be family groups of
meat-eating dinosaurs it's interesting
the only you know we find these things
mostly in the late or in the Cretaceous
and and late jurassic I don't know Steve
will have to tell you whether we have
such a thing in the Triassic I was like
I don't know about that I try to stay on
the Triassic yeah things like sila
physis I guess in the Triassic you know
you have big accumulations sometimes not
quite as as vast of bone Betances maybe
some of these horned dinosaurs or
ductile dinosaurs and late cretaceous
but yeah there's some some evidence in
the Triassic
Joe Brody gets back to the film but sort
of turns it on its head says obviously
science and forms films about dinosaurs
but what about the reverse are there any
techniques or technologies more
typically associated with modern
high-tech moviemaking eg fleet the CGI
that are now being used to help
scientists understand more about
dinosaurs physiology movements etc no
right Steve you better get down because
I know people are using a lot of CG
techniques to model dinosaurs yeah yeah
it's a bit you know outside of the realm
of what I do but we do have some
colleagues people like John Hutchinson
and others that make digital models of
dinosaurs using some of the general
technologies of movie makers use and
then when you have a digital model you
scan in the skip the bones and then you
can digitally add muscle and flash and
kind of the other softest and you know
make these things do various gymnastics
routines whatever you want to make them
do and see what's plausible what kind of
postures are plausible what kind of
speeds are plausible and so some of them
you know digital CGI type techniques do
play into modeling dinosaurs in that way
okay questions have stuff rolling in I
will mind those of you who are listening
that you can still send in questions in
the leave a message box other related
articles and you've got just a just a
few minutes left so if you've got
anything you're dying to find out about
now is the time okay um Valerie asks how
different was the climate during the
Dino era compared to today and how might
that affect a project like Jurassic Park
theoretically well we're talking about
about 150 million years and the whole
world is it even num doesn't even make
sense to talk about how different the
climate was
the dinosaur era not to me yeah it's a
long stretch of time I mean when
dinosaurs originated this was a time of
Pangaea well when all the world's
continents were gathered together but
when dinosaurs except for birds went
extinct the Cotton's pretty much were in
the positions they are today so the
world changed pretty drastically but in
general the time of dinosaurs with
warmer than today there's more co2 in
the atmosphere and there is today there
weren't polar ice caps or at least big
polar ice caps but yeah I mean things
changed quite dramatically over that
time so there's you know really no such
thing as the dinosaur climate we're
there polar dinosaurs yes well yeah
there were dinosaurs above the Arctic
Circle there were dinosaurs below this
site without antarctic sir Homer above I
don't know that above or below oh noes
anyway yes there are four dinosaurs and
they would have you know they as far as
we can tell live there all year long
some of them at least and that means
that they had a period of darkness which
is very interesting I think that's
something that we're trying to address
with our bone histology and actually
looking to see if in fact we see any
different growth patterns and and
although some people have suggested
there are different growth patterns I
think we're really learning more
recently that they look about the same
they're sort of all doing the same thing
whether they're in the darker not
let's see people seem very interested in
parents okay trying to get here let's
not paleontology so lost about chaos
theory
it would have been definitely chaotic if
you would have put all those dinosaurs
in that than those small pens that they
had in Jurassic Park that that I
guarantee would have been pure chaos
okay Peter Krause also asks what are the
chances for Raptors claws Iguanodon
spurs being poisonous now when we this
is specular we have no idea if the
Iguanodon maybe use it its first for
visual display when courting females
just like Triceratops uses by seven tops
uses its horns for social communication
do we know what these anything about the
the movies take some artistic license
with poisonous dinosaurs is there any
way of knowing whether it's such things
actually existed nothing we know of you
know we don't you know if you think
about birds I mean I know Steve can
address this but you know I cassowary is
a bird we have alive today and we don't
really know what it does with the crest
on its head so you know trying to figure
out what the Holies dinosaurs did with
all ur parts pretty hard to do yeah I
mean so many different kinds of
dinosaurs had various fantastic features
you know the spikes of and then plates
of stegosaurs or the horns and frills of
ceratopsians or the domes of you know
Pachycephalosaurus whatever the case may
be and you know I think in general we
think that most of those things were
used for display but they may have had
other functions as well they may have
been used in defense or may have been
used to help regulate body temperature
or whatever the case could be as far as
venom goes that's a really tricky thing
to address I'm not sure of any you know
slam-dunk correlates of venom that we
can see in the claws of something like a
dromaeosaurus egestas that some
dinosaurs had venomous teeth the
evidence for that is very weak in fact
the evidence is just wrong so we have no
knowledge of any type of venomous
dinosaur doesn't mean it was impossible
but it's one of these tricky things I'm
sure someday somebody will find
some some good evidence but for now
nothing that I know of okay well we're
getting down to the mark here and so let
Valerie have the last word here she she
asked both of you with what do you think
when you consider the biggest unanswered
question in paleontology and I know that
scientists hate questions like that but
the rest of us really love them so I'm
afraid I'm going to put you on the spot
with this well I i I'd really hate that
question because I asked actually think
that that we probably don't know what
question to ask and as long as we try to
ask questions that sort of already sort
of pins us down as to what kind of
answer we might have like I think the
best thing we can do in any science is
keep an open mind and try not to let
preconceived ideas alter the way we
think yeah I agree with that totally and
I don't want to bunt down to question
but um I think that we're always
learning new things about dinosaurs or
even about living animals and we were
constantly learning new things and a lot
of the new things we learn kind of come
about by chance depending on what fossil
discoveries we make so I think we just
have to broadly remain interested in the
two big questions of dinosaur evolution
dinosaur behavior and keep trying to
find fossils and you know we'll see
where the research takes us I think when
you plan out research like that it never
goes as well as when you just kind of
take it as it comes I think a few years
ago nobody would have predicted we could
have been finding evidence of color in
dinosaurs but that just emerged by
chance from some research that some
people were doing on color in other
groups of animals so I don't want to pin
anything down I think the work that
we're all doing is quite broad and who
knows what the next great discovery will
be and I think that we'll just have to
leave it at that thank you wealth of you
dr. Horner dr. Prasad e for making
yourselves available for just every
question that our readers can throw at
you tho those of you who are here now oh
well please sub join us next thursday
april eighteenth for a live chat on
genetic privacy which as far as i know
will have nothing whatsoever to do with
dinosaurs thank you very much yeah my
pleasure take care of me alright alright